Jason Statham stars and transporter for
the mechanic no this is not a film about
a really awesome auto repair man Jason
Statham stars as the mechanic he is a
hit man he gets things done he fixes
things you get it the film chronicles
his attempts to train another mechanic
played by Ben Foster the trailer really
suggests it's just flat-out action but
there's actually a lot more to this
movie has a lot of drama in it but I'm
not saying that as a good thing Jason's
say there was a likable action hero but
in all honesty pretty much plays the
same character in all his movies he's
basically the transporter in every movie
that he's in now I have not seen all of
his films I have not seen the bank job I
know that got good reviews but my
favorite of his films is probably the
Italian Job essentially this is
transporter for you seem like they try
to add on all these things that were
unnecessary to the story it didn't seem
necessary some of the sex scenes and
stuff to just have them you know like
we're going to have this now I had
nothing to do with the story in fact
characters were introduced into these
people's lives that had literally
nothing to do with the story it was just
so they could have a sex scene it was
them to just seem like they were trying
to make the film more adult by doing
like default things that seemed adult
you know what I mean like they weren't
actually making the story adult level
they were just throwing on things in the
movie to make it seem more adult that
didn't have to be there I like Jason
Statham he's not a bad actor he's a good
action star he really is just playing
the same character over over and I like
the guy I do I think he's fun I like his
character in this film I actually cared
about his character I just I want to see
him do something different Ben Foster I
real
don't like there's just something about
Ben Foster that annoys me though it
might be his face
it seems rude he's character annoyed the
crap out of me he wants to do all these
things for himself but not take Jason
Statham's advice I just got under my
skin you know the first half of the
movie was actually pretty slow-moving to
be honest in the action scenes they fall
into that same thing where the whole
time I'm thinking zoom out for goodness
sakes please are the filmmakers afraid
to show a fight in like one take the
director of this movie is Simon West he
directed Conair a movie I really like
but that's because of the strengths of
three performances John Cusack Nicolas
Cage and John Malkovich this film does
not have that kind of strength there are
no performances in this film that stand
out as anything special so it's just a
very mediocre action movie for the most
part the film is watchable but there are
so many things about it that just got
under my skin do something else it's
just so standard it has some good action
Jason Statham as a likable hero I
actually really liked the ending of this
film but annoying characters characters
doing things that don't make any sense
very flat direction Simon West tends to
use close-ups all the time and it seemed
like you use a different shot like every
Sundance a character would say come on
just show the two characters on the same
frame conversing I know it sounds boring
but it's more entertain than cut cut cut
cut
some of this stuff really gets under my
skin I'm not saying you're not going to
enjoy this film it it is a very
watchable action movie but for my
director standpoint which is what I tend
to look at there are so many flaws in
this film and it just really got under
my skin after a while there are likable
things here there are good things here
there's entertainment value here it's
just lost in this film that's seems like
it's trying to be something it's not see
movie like this needs to be fun but the
characters that inhabit this world are
so solemn and dreadful and dreary that
you can't have fun with it so I'm gonna
give the mechanic 2 out of 4 stars it
just seemed like the filmmakers were
trying to make a film that was not on
the page and the source of the film is
that script if it's not in the script
it's not going to be in the movie so two
out of four stars for the mechanic